Ryan another self this this is a
deadline coincidentally also today as
well as the IMF payment by Greece but
this is a self-imposed deadline it looks
as if it's going to be missed though
yeah i mean this deadline is dead and
the new deadline might be july the 7th
the idea being that the negotiators
think that they're close enough to a
deal that they can actually get one but
within a couple of days if they want to
get if the Obama administration has a
deal in Vienna and wants to take it back
to the Congress then it would be great
to have that by the 7th so they can get
it through Congress before they go on
holiday there's a lot of impetus to
these talks so we have the president's
brother joining the Iranian Foreign
Minister he's an aide to the president
we have the head of the Atomic Energy
Agency there as well the Iranian Foreign
Minister coming back from Tehran today
that's the expectation that's where he
went on Sunday because we still have two
obstacles outlined or highlighted by the
Supreme Leader of Iran last week and
that is one access to these sensitive
sites he says he doesn't want anything
unconventional and to exactly how you
know quickly we'll get sanctions relief
the iranian supreme leader wants quick
sanctions relief unsurprisingly the
negotiators the world powers are saying
no it has to be staged and they do say
that privately that's been agreed to in
any case so there's a lot of hope at
this point but it's not going to be
today and how is all this being
reflected in the oil price well look you
know you look at oil it's been going
down for the last five days part of that
is Iran these leaders keep saying that
we're we're getting closer to a deal
Iran exports about a million barrels a
day right now if they're brought into
the fold within six months time they say
they could double that to two million
barrels a day but grace is also a factor
and the concern with grace is well is is
the demand picture and that's one of the
things that you know if you listen to
OPEC carefully they've been really quite
bullish about is the demand picture
going to remain as robust as it was if
Greece does go belly-up and and there's
contagion within Europe but generally
speaking the concern is mostly about the
glut you look at the United States us
inventories there
they've come down to about 30 million
barrels so we had four hundred and
ninety-three million barrels eight weeks
ago we're down to 463 we're going to get
numbers new numbers tomorrow that tell
us about last week and the expectation
is that the glut will have reduced still
more but you know we're still well above
the five-year average and that's why if
you look at the hedge funds as well
they're still bullish but there they
have the least number of bullish bets
the least number of bets that suggests
that the price of oil is going to go up
in three months